I am a hipster. I am an honest-to-god,
dyed-in-the-wool EDH hipster. I like to
play weird, unusual decks that do weird,
unusual things with weird, unusual
cards. The idea that I might be playing
a deck that does something nobody has
done before is extremely cool to me. And
that specific task is something that is
far more possible to do in EDH than in
just about any other format. The format
has a card selection that's almost as
wide as Vintage is. It has thousands of
different options for commanders. And
the fact that it doesn't have a single
set power level means that no deck is
fully squeezed out as long as you're
willing to shop around for an
appropriate table to play at. The level
of freedom that the format offers to
deck builders can be genuinely
overwhelming for the people who aren't
used to that. But for the most dedicated
brewers of the world, it's basically one
big playground of possibilities.
Do you have a funky vision you want to
realize? EDH can absolutely accommodate
that.
I do firmly believe all that about the
format, and I have long had the goal of
pushing the envelope on how weird and
niche casual EDH can get. But for the
past couple months, I've also had a
nagging thought.
Is the version of the EDH format I'm
describing actually a good one? One that
leads the most people to have the most
fun?
Is having a weird-off with the table
where everybody tries to do the most
performatively unusual things actually a
good way to play Magic?
Might it even be more ethical, better to
one's fellow Magic players, to play a
deck that's simpler or does something
more common? So, in this video, I'm
going to explore that nagging doubt. But
first, I need to lay out a bit of
context.
The period between 2002 and 2011 saw the
EDH format grow from a scarcely known
novelty to a format Wizards of the Coast
was willing to print cards specifically
for. A big step in this process was its
adoption as a casual pick-up format
among Pro Tour judges, with the late
Sheldon Menery effectively serving as
the format's guide and foremost advocate
during this period and beyond.
The appeal here is clear. It was a more
casual way of playing that could
manifest at events once the more
cutthroat 1v1 matches of the day had
been concluded.
Even after the first precons were
released, this culture of pickup games
remained strong across the format.
Anecdotally, I played a decent amount of
Commander during downtime at local
limited and standard events in 2014 and
2015, and it just made sense as a format
to play when people were looking for a
bit of variety.
In his article for Polygon a few years
back, Charlie Hall highlighted some of
the appeals. If a handful of people want
to play a game of Magic, rather than
figuring out an appropriate format to
play or double-checking that a couple
casual decks are built under similar
ethos, Commander offers an elegant
one-size-fits-all solution with a broad
card pool and a slim ban list.
Though EDH has since become its own main
event in most cases, played among friend
groups and in dedicated leagues at local
game stores, there are visible
indications of the lingering influence
of pickup games in the direction Wizards
of the Coast has taken with the products
they market to Commander players.
While they used to sell a product called
Deck Builder's Toolkit as a way for
casual players to build their first deck
on their own time, these got phased out
a few years ago to be replaced with
greater Arena support and more products
for Commander, the now de facto casual
format of paper magic.
Relevant to my point here, most of these
products are preconstructed Commander
decks, which are ready to play out of
the box. If you're sitting in a game
store and a few other people start to
play Commander, you can walk up to the
counter to buy a precon and some
sleeves, and you'll be good to go in a
few minutes, assuming you have a couple
helpful compatriots to help you sleeve
up.
Now, at this point you may be saying,
"But Alex, how is this relevant?" Well,
let's take a minute to think about the
pickup EDH experience, where you sit
down to a table and start up a casual
EDH game with three unfamiliar opponents
who are playing largely unfamiliar
decks.
Put simply, it can be a little
overwhelming sometimes, and I'm speaking
purely from an information standpoint.
With the format being slow and
four-player, the board gets gradually
clogged with increasing numbers of
assorted permanence of various stripes,
with the purpose of any single one being
potentially unclear. And this is EDH in
the year of our Lord 2024. So, all of
these have a lot of text, too much text,
some might argue. With thousands of
Commander options, there's a good chance
of at least one of these at the table
being one you haven't played against.
Knowledge of how your opponents plan to
win will likely be incomplete at best,
and next to nonexistent at worst if
nobody bothered to pose that question to
the table.
Pick up EDH can be an absolute
information overload, and this broader
problem can be broken down into two
separate subproblems, card diversity and
gameplay diversity.
As far as card diversity goes, the EDH
format has tens of thousands of cards
available to it, and a much less
restrictive ban list than Legacy, which
otherwise shares a similar card pool.
Not only this, but since the format is
100 card singleton, seeing any singular
card in a deck gives far fewer
implications for what the rest of the
deck might contain compared to other
formats, and also results in far more
unique cards in each deck.
Multiply this by three to account for
the multiplayer aspect of the format,
and there will be a lot of cards to keep
track of just as a baseline.
Traditionally, veterans of a given
format will be better able to keep up
with different things opponents are
playing due to wider card knowledge, but
with Wizards of the Coast increasing the
number of brand new cards they print
into the Commander format from the high
hundreds per year to multiple thousand
per year, keeping up even as an
experienced EDH player can be difficult.
My friend Hans built a funky new deck
recently, and even as somebody who
basically thinks about EDH as a
profession, there were a surprising
number of cards from this deck that I
had no familiarity with whatsoever.
In a game with several decks containing
unfamiliar cards, just processing these
new pieces of cardboard and figuring out
how to play against them in real time
can eat up precious mental energy that
could otherwise go toward planning
future turns, politicking, and
performing threat analysis on other
cards. And that's with a group of
experienced players.
The new player in EDH is a whole
different beast. While the number of
different non-land cards in opponent's
decks in a 60-card 1v1 format might be
somewhere in the 15 to 20 range, in EDH
that number might be 10 times that
amount. Getting a foothold in that
environment will be a difficult and
time-consuming process even in a setting
with somewhat consistent decks and
players. And in an environment with
rapidly changing decks and players, this
is amplified. I'm not saying it's
impossible. There are plenty of magic
players who have learned the game
through EDH, and I'm sure there are some
who even thrived in this
high-stimulation, information-dense
environment. There are also likely
plenty of people who learned the format
somewhat more gradually, but who had
plenty of fun throughout the whole
process, even if they weren't keeping up
100% the whole time.
I certainly don't think it's worth
anyone's time and energy to push players
away from the Commander format. It has
clearly taken a hold of casual magic,
and there are lots of aspects of it that
are likely fun for newer players.
What I am saying, though, is that
increasing the card diversity of decks
does meaningfully increase the length of
time it'll take for a new player to get
a foothold within the format. When I
made my video about cEDH a few months
back, I got a number of interesting
comments from people who prefer
competitive EDH specifically because
there are fewer viable cards in the
format that require keeping track of. A
few of these were people who had jumped
straight into cEDH from a 60-card format
or a different card game entirely, and
this makes sense on some level. If
you're looking to play Commander
seriously, and you don't want to have to
bother with learning the thousands upon
thousands of cards you might see in
casual EDH, cEDH is a nice alternative.
It may even be, as a casual EDH player
in the comments pondered, a smoother
experience for those wanting to play
Commander with strangers for more
reasons than one.
I see this as the most reasonable
response to my main gripe with cEDH.
Yes, fewer cards are viable, and that's
good, actually.
The issue of the EDH format's card
diversity is compounded when decks are
equally diverse in their play patterns.
The origins of the format were people
throwing together their bulk cards they
couldn't play in Standard and playing
them under the banner of a commander
that was vaguely related at best. And
this likely resulted in unfocused blobs
of mid-range being a dominant deck type,
maybe with some funky synergies coming
to the fore here and there.
And as a casual pick-up format, this
makes sense. If decks are built more to
produce relaxed games and showcase
unusual cards than to win, the presence
of those cards can take center stage.
Like, sure, you might have to refresh
yourself on what Frailly Supplicant
does, but it's probably not going to
rapidly spell your downfall.
However, as decks have gotten more
streamlined and have started to
accomplish increasingly specific tasks
increasingly quickly,
lacking knowledge of the ins and outs of
what your opponent's deck is doing
starts to become more of a problem.
As you might expect, this effect also
scales with power level up to a certain
point.
If you're playing against unaltered
precons, you can usually at least assume
there will be some sort of synergy-based
mid-range thing going on along with a
couple predictable side synergy
packages. If you're playing against a
handful of mid-power mid-range decks,
there will likely be less certainty and
more surprises, but you still can
probably get at least a rough idea of
what's going on without knowing the
opposing decks.
However, it's the power level I'd
describe as high-power casual where
things start to feel really weird when
playing with strangers. Infinite combos,
locks, and back-breakingly powerful
value engines get assembled on a whim,
and with only relatively subtle hints to
indicate their approach. Whereas in
CEDH, there is a smaller group of viable
strategies with off-meta tech being a
spicy exception rather than the rule,
high-power casual is packed to the
rafters with off-meta because there
isn't a meaningful meta beyond some
archetypes being a bit more popular than
others.
Now, I do love me some high-power
casual, and I can even see a sort of
weird allure in playing with unfamiliar
people and unfamiliar decks. It's a zany
explosive form of magic where games are
often quick, and where there's a ton of
sleuthing the ins and outs of opposing
decks that happens on the fly.
But I'd also wager that this is where a
big dose of frustration comes from in
pick-up magic, particularly in games
that straddle the line between mid and
high power, and where players enter with
differing expectations. If everybody is
already needing to process the cards and
decks of three different opponents, and
they don't know the cohesive plan of any
one opponent, let alone three,
well, this is an environment where it's
very easy to slip through a power play
that opponents just aren't equipped to
challenge.
Sure, one could argue just hold up
removal, but that misunderstands the
nature of threat assessment. If I know
my opponent's decks, I can think to
myself, "Okay, I'm 90% sure player A
doesn't have the pieces to combo off on
their next turn, and player B should be
two mana short of a game-winning spell."
And then decisions can be made on
whether to hold up interaction based on
if I have other useful plays to make
that outweigh that risk.
But, if instead of being 85% sure it's
safe to tap out, I have no firm estimate
whatsoever,
what exactly am I supposed to do? Hold
up mana every turn?
The answer is probably hold up mana when
it's nice to do so, and don't when it's
not, and maybe do my best to follow
context clues, but then on some level
it's just a random luck check for
whether or not I lose to some
right?
This effect is unfortunately amplified
the more unique ways of gaining
advantage and winning exist within a
game. You can keep track of some number
of cards commonly associated with
combos, but when decks have plans that
are weird or unconventional, there will
be plenty of things that slip through
the cracks. In competitive terms, you
might call this brewer's advantage, but
in a casual context, it can create
dynamics that aren't necessarily
positive for everybody involved. With
all that in mind, it might make sense
that the experience that gave me my love
for weird offbeat EDH decks was actually
an environment that had basically none
of these problems. From the fall of 2019
to the summer of 2021, my playgroup of
five people played about 200 games with
a set of 10 budget decks, with each deck
seeing an average of one major rebuild
over the course of those two years.
Though several of these decks were
quirky and evocative, and though the
card choices in them got pretty funky,
the fact that we were exclusively
playing with these 10 guild divided
decks meant that the plans for each deck
and the cards used within those plans
became all but public knowledge.
Multiple players basically learned the
game through this pool and despite the
diversity within the pool, this was an
ideal environment for that. You could
learn the game pieces and what each deck
was doing reasonably easily and even if
you'd forgotten something, other players
at the table were likely vocalizing
relevant information.
If you don't think about it too hard,
you might assume that this trait is
shared by a lot of casual playgroups.
And yes, the best arguments against
decks with unusual cards and unique game
plans do relate to pick-up games with
largely unfamiliar opponents. But plenty
of these arguments also apply to games
within dedicated playgroups.
For one, players these days often have a
lot of decks. While the idea of building
a second Commander deck was silly to me
in 2015, a quick poll in the Patreon
channel of our Discord server showed
that around 60% of respondents had at
least eight decks.
While the average is probably lower than
this, I have to imagine a lot of
dedicated playgroups still feature a
hefty number of unique decks among the
various players, well above the 10 seen
at my table a few years back. In
addition, not all playgroups meet
frequently enough to fully keep track of
the ins and outs of each other's decks.
While my small playgroup of 20-year-olds
played several games a week at the
height of pandemic-fueled boredom,
plenty of Magic players are busy adults
with time-consuming jobs, time-consuming
children, and extremely dedicated
all-bar D&D campaign, or some
combination of these things.
There also might be a somewhat rotating
player group with fresh decks being a
regular sighting. Under these sorts of
circumstances, much of the information
overload present in pick-up EDH will
likely also be present. And if this is
the case, one could argue that players
playing simpler decks with more commonly
seen cards may very well lead to more
fun for everybody at the table.
So, that's my case for why running funky
unique decks is not an unquestioned good
and can in fact amplify one of the
biggest problems with the casual EDH
format, the overwhelming amount of
information it presents players with.
And let me be clear, I find this
argument extremely interesting, almost
paralyzingly interesting.
And yet, the deck building conclusions
that it gestures at run almost perfectly
contradictory to the hipster tendencies
that all but define my deck building
style. So, how do we square that circle?
Well, for starters, in all of the
examples I gave of what might constitute
a bad experience as a result of decks
being weird and unusual, there are tons
of other factors that might contribute
to the information density at the table.
For example, I emphasized that this
issue is vastly more problematic in
settings with strangers and unknown
decks, but the unknowability of decks
isn't a set-in-stone thing. You and your
opponents can tell each other what your
decks do, and you can go into whatever
amount of detail suits the decks present
and suits the game you want to play.
Whenever I play with new people at my
local game store, I'll generally give
some explanation of the deck I'm playing
while I'm shuffling up, and I'll often
ask for the same from my opponents. Even
when it's trading relatively simple
explanations, this act can allow players
to go into games with a sense of
groundedness, having at least some idea
of what they're getting into.
There are also additional actions during
games that can further elucidate what's
happening within a game, and a
relatively basic one I've seen pretty
often is verbally differentiating
commonly game-ending spells from other
spells. For example, saying, "I play
Llanowar Elves" versus "I attempt to
cast Skyshroud Elf." I like this a lot
because it's not even an insult to the
game knowledge of your opponents. On the
contrary, you're treating them like
seasoned veterans of playing against
your deck, who would know that you
resolving Skyshroud Elf is a problem, or
at least something worth paying full
attention to.
I'll even sometimes draw attention to
important information I've revealed.
When I'm playing my Francisco Malcolm
deck against people who haven't played
against it much before, if I reveal a
Shred Memory off of an Explorer on turn
four, I might say something like, "I'll
keep Shred Memory on top. There's a
particular two-mana card I might want to
transmute for sometime soon." as a
gentle reminder of what my deck is
trying to do.
Now, that's the only deck I give that
amount of information for since it's a
deceptively fast combo deck that's
generally on the more powerful end of my
store's high-power casual pods, but
that's just an example of how giving
extra information can reduce whiplash
and lead to a better play experience.
Another method I've commonly seen is
keeping revealed cards revealed longer
than is required, most often putting a
revealed card into hand face up for a
turn or two, or leaving the revealed top
card of a library face up until it's
drawn.
This likewise removes a bit of mental
strain from opponents by not requiring
them to immediately commit revealed
cards to memory.
Some of this might seem a bit obvious,
but I feel the need to say it explicitly
because I got a lot of confusing
comments on my Commander as a combo
piece video from players who seem to
think that deception is a key feature of
the EDH format. Not bluffing, like
purposefully concealing key details
about the cards contained within one's
deck for purposes of pulling off a
gotcha win.
This is obviously fine in competitive
formats since there is a meta
counter-meta dynamic at play, and I
imagine some people enjoy playing this
way in casual EDH as well.
However, to reiterate an earlier point,
decks being unknown makes threat
assessment vastly more difficult and as
a result injects a lot of extra luck
into games, and I certainly don't find
that enjoyable personally.
I also find the idea of trying to sneak
through an explosive win against a table
who's not prepared for or looking for
that kind of EDH to be a little
distasteful, but that's subjective
territory and I can't claim to know the
desires of any particular EDH table, so
I won't throw any extra words at that
particular subject. Beyond the gameplay
methods for getting around this
information overload, there can also be
attributes of decks at the table that
affect the degree of information
present. Is this the part of the video
where I find yet another excuse to tell
you to play more removal? Well, kind of,
but not exactly.
The other big thing that made the $25
deck pool I used to play so good for
avoiding information overload was that
the decks were interaction dense, as
well as low-slung and grindy to be able
to handle the aforementioned
interaction.
The fact that the pool began with two
board wipe dense control decks meant
that every midrange deck was designed
with the goal of not overcommitting to
board, which means fewer non-land
permanents on the board and less of the
escalation type cards that typically
pump mid-sized midrange boards up to
being alarming masses of assorted
permanents in a lot of casual EDH games.
I should be clear. This worked well
because these 10 decks formed a little
meta, and your mileage may vary in
multiple regards if you try to emulate
any of this in a pod of more
conventionally built EDH decks. However,
it does gesture at a vision for EDH
that's much more approachable than a lot
of what I see at local game stores. And
while it's not necessarily a vision that
can or should be copied, it gives a
useful benchmark to reference for what
EDH can look like.
When removal is absent and everybody is
just allowed to do their deck's
snowballing midrange thing, board states
often end up utterly caked in the extra
noise of various synergy permanents and
utility creatures and tokens, and I
think it's always worth asking the
question of if that's a worthwhile way
to play, and if there are ways to avoid
that sort of board state. Beyond my
practical recommendations, I also think
it's worth considering what EDH
represents. Because you may have noticed
that the potential version of EDH I
gestured at earlier in the video, one
where decks operate within a narrower
set of potential game plans with a
narrower range of cards, is one that
more closely resembles 60-card formats.
Chasing this vision for the format might
have its benefits in some ways, but at
what cost? There are so many things that
can only be done in EDH, and so many
cards that aren't really viable or even
legal in most other formats. I think
it's worth considering the case that EDH
can be an overwhelming format at times,
and I think it's also worth considering
how to mitigate those problems.
It might even be worthwhile for newer
players to try and sprinkle some variety
into their MTG diet. I'm of the opinion
that almost all magic players can
benefit from playing limited, and cube
can give a nice way to play limited
without feeling like you're wasting
money on packs that you haven't yet
developed the skill to fully utilize.
But, no. Reducing the variety of the
format isn't the solution, and it isn't
worth it. The creation of the original
Elder Dragon Highlander format is often
credited to Adam Staley, and Staley
conceptualized the format as a way to
inject variety and creativity into a
game whose constructed formats were
already rigid and meta-driven, even in
the first few years of the game.
Singleton meant being forced to play
with underutilized cards. A wide card
pool meant that decks could be
constructed with basically any old cards
sitting around, and a higher life total
meant more space for creative but slower
strategies that would likely get
squeezed out by faster decks in a 20
health format. An Elder Dragon at the
head of things gave an undeniable
symbolic core to decks.
A format as large as EDH can't be solely
governed by the vision of one man 30
years ago, but you have to admit, he was
kind of onto something.